respiratory burst is a process by which
reactive oxygen species is used by all
the phagocytes to kill bacteria or
pathogens
cells like macrophages neutrophils and
dendritic cell can undergo the process
of respiratory burst during the process
of respiratory burst oxygen is converted
into superoxide radical with the help of
nadph oxidase then it can eventually be
converted into H2O2 with help of
superoxide dismutase H2O2 get converted
into hocl free radical all these
reactive oxygen species can damage the
bacteria Ross can lead to lipid
peroxidation disintegrity in the
membrane it can compromise the
functionality of the protein eventually
it can even damage the DNA thereby
killing the bacteria under circumstances
where nadph oxidase is mutated it leads
to a problem known as chronic
granulomotives